thank you
welcome everyone
um
welcome to this presentation so today i
will talk about data unit tests
and what they are exactly and why we
need them but first let me ask a real
quick question who is having data
quality issues
please raise your hand
yes
exactly i'm also in the yeah
so let's go into the agenda
and
i will begin with a short introduction
and
with that i will
after define what our data unit test and
explain their importance and
especially when we are want to build
data products
then we'll go into uh i will present
some frameworks that you can use to
perform data unit tests and i will also
show
some
some live code
and
then in third i will explain
how we
tackle it at get your guide my company
and finally i will conclude and open for
questions and also discussions
um
yes
let's get started so
as little say so i will present myself
so i'm theodore data scientist i get
your guide and actually in my company
what we do is we build a marketplace for
travel experiences
and especially in my team
we are responsible for the
recommendations and the ranking of the
experiences on the platform
so that means that we actually
uh rely heavily on the data uh that we
have to achieve our goals that means
that like we're building data products
so and that's why today i want to talk
um
about data unit tests
because
data
data products actually combine the code
and the data and you need both to have
something that is useful for the the
business at the end
actually if we in classical software
development
it's
a common practice to ensure the quality
of your of your product
with automated tests
and actually here you focus your tests
you focus on testing the code
however if you want to ensure the
quality of your data product then you
need to validate not only the code but
you should validate the data
make sense right
and one way to validate the data then is
to have test well data unit test
and let's let's step back actually
if you work on an organization that is
have multiple engineering teams the
probably the code uh is owned by the
team that you are working on and you
probably have the you have the one that
has the most context around
the the data product that you're
building so when you are changing it you
know that you are changing it and you
have the full context around it
however
if the company organization is
a certain size you and your the data
that you are using is not produced by
you and not transformed by you it's
transformed by other teams right
and
they probably do not have the full
context
of how you are using the data afterwards
and just an example in my company and i
think we are pretty normal here like for
our uh for our ranking and our
recommended algorithm we are combining
around 15 uh different data sources
but we are not owning the the production
of this data or the transformation of
this data
so
what are data unit test data unit tests
let's dive into a
really more precise definition is some
kind of expectations that you have on
the uh on your production data so the
data you will use for your data products
so for example i think you have to make
a clear distinction between
testing like for example if you if you
want to test that your algorithm
is able to handle some null value that's
a unit test like a normal unit a code
unit test
that's you should do that that's great
however testing that the data set you
will use to train your model or to
to pass through your pipeline does not
have no
this is where you need data unit just to
be sure that it's not happening
and so some examples of things that you
might want to check
for example you might want to check that
the the mean the max of the average of a
column uh
value uh
is okay you might want to check that you
are not uh you do not have to do not
have no value or at least not too many
missing value you might accept to have
some no but not expect to have more than
50 percent of them
you might verify that you do not have
too many duplicates column or that you
do not have duplicates not too many of
them it depends on the what's
what you expect from your data and
another example the number of sample
that you have is reasonable you
probably have some expectation all
around that and that's the kind of thing
that you can check with data unit test
great
so
now that's we have a more precise idea
of data unit tests and let's look at the
main frameworks that you can
that you can use to perform then and i
think the first one i want to talk about
is a great expectation so it's the most
active projects
and it supports actually most of the
format so you can use sql you can
connect it with some
um
with databases and you can also use
pandas
uh and also pi spark so that's i think
one the main formats that uh people are
using so that's pretty great
they also render some data documentation
so it's a kind of human readable
documentation about around
the data that's um
around the data expectation that you
have sold to the data unit test that you
are building with them then we have
pandera which is also quite active and
actually that has no company behind uh
to the opposite of great expectations so
it's like open source maintained by
benevolent people
and
the thing it's mainly built for pandas
they just added the the pi spark
uh support very recently and actually
they are using the pi spark
the pandas
api to do that so they are transforming
everything into pandas to do this this
check
um
[Music]
and here the the thing is they are more
focused on validating the schema
whereas great expectation is more taking
a global approach and checking more
things than just the schema
and also they do not have uh
visualizations
like data the data kind of data
documentation that great expectation
proposed
then uh we have also uh tensorflow data
validation which is part of tensorflow
extended
where i i was quite surprised so it
still has quite have uh some stars but
actually not very active at the moment
and uh the idea another drawback is also
it's quite integrated with the
tensorflow ecosystem so if you're not
full in tensorflow then probably it's
hard to to integrate it with
something else with the rest of your
infrastructure
and finally uh soda
which is i
uh what i
researched very similar to great
expectation it's a more recent project
they also propose like sql by spark
but also uh
they are newer so i think we can they
also why they have less popularity on
github and everything but
i i see them i
really in the same space and great
expectations
and so to conclude i think the the most
mature and the most feature complete
library is great expectations
and
then i will just focus on that for the
for to explain a bit more how you can
build expectations and show the live
code so let's dive into some of the main
features of great expectation
so
first you have this concept of
expectation
so it's kind of a session about the data
and that's basically what uh we call it
this data unit test you the most common
use case actually are already
implemented in the library so you don't
have to do it so if you want to check
that um a colon do not have no that's uh
colon uh mean and uh min and max is uh
in this uh values that the mean
the
the median et cetera all this kind of
basic
things are already implemented there
and also they render this
sorry and of course if you have some
very specific use case then you can
always add them so you can spray your
specific use case uh specific assertion
that you want to do you can also
implement them by yourself
then what i also have is data profiling
so what you can do is actually load the
data set that you know is
good that you you you manual check and
then basically pass it to this profiling
and that will give you a draft of
expectation that you can use you will
still need to modify them it's not
perfect but at least you don't start
from scratch
then they also have
of course when you have all these data
this this expectation and
then you want to do some validation and
so you can validate new data sets um
with a defined collection of
expectations that you built before
and you all can also get some alerting
via email slacks if something is going
wrong
and finally
data documentation
and can think of uh so it's auto render
documentation of the data that you that
you you are checking or
and you can think of a constantly
updated data quality reports
but
i think that
code is more is worth more than 1000
slides so i will show you
how to create some data unit tests using
great expectation
and
yes
because so i'm french actually it might
have heard from the accent um so i will
talk about wine
so i took the the wine quality data set
so actually it's composed of
two data sets the red wine data sets
that we'll use to generate the test
and then we'll
load the white wine data set and that's
the one we will try to validate based on
the test that will build on the red wine
so here i'm using databricks which
is something that we really heavily use
in my company but you can work actually
with uh other clouds or
it's actually a
jupiter notebook based more than
databrick space
yeah so let's get started so we need to
install great
expectation then we need to have two
imports the thing in the library
and then we can
load the raid
the red wine data set
basically like we have a different
columns
and uh at the end like about some
measurement about the wine and at the
end we have a quality score which is an
integer between 0 and 10. and so we'll
focus on two main columns the sulfates
here and the quality
that's the two one that we all may i
will focus on for this presentation so
then let's set up some uh the gr to set
up to run great expectation on data
breaks and for the sake of time actually
so we can dive into the code so you have
the the link i will share the slide at
the end and you have the link to this
notebook and so you can also clone it
run it check the code itself but for the
sake of sign i will not go into the the
code to set up
a great expectation databricks but
what's
important is at the end we get a
validator
which is basically an object which we
can use to build test and in here you
already have the data set the red wine
data set attached to to this object and
you can run directly there
and so let's build
data unit tests so the first one
as a part of the documentation indeed we
expect the column quality we to be in
the range between 0 and 10 so it should
be an integer in this range so let's run
the let's do the test and actually it
will run on this red wine data set
and it did yes the obstacle value are
between three and eight actually no no
not the full scale and we get some
results and the tests succeed
great looks good then let's run the
second test
and so for that uh what we will do is uh
let's we want to expect like the sulfate
distribution uh on the data data set to
be to be fixed so first we will build an
histogram from the current data set and
then we will perform a callback library
divergence test
so in practice that means that if the
distribution of the data set that you
put is very different or different from
this histogram
then the test will fail so basically
just check that you have the same
distribution
and so we can run this test also
and yes and we get like the different
bins and things like that
so when we are done what we can do
basically is
save the uh
expectation suite so that's a collection
of expectations that we just built
and once it's done then
we can actually generate some
documentation about the
the code that we just put
and here what we have basically is
a human readable
format where html
that can basically explain like what
what we just built so actually the
quality we expect the value to be
between 0 and 10 and we expect the
distribution to be similar to this
which is great i think that's something
that you can share with any of your
stakeholders and they don't need to go
into the code to say that's exactly
you can show them something much nicer
than
some
github
code base
so now we are done
let's
load the new uh the white wine data sets
and
yes and we'll see pretty similar they
are the same columns and also soft item
quality and let's run the test on this
wine dataset so here
perfect and let's run the test also
and at the end what you get is a
automatic report so basically you have
another html and
here
you will get
c we have like 50
so actually we have one failure
so let's look into the report so the
quality
is indeed between 0 and 10 also actually
we see we also have the value 9 that
appeared that we didn't have before
sorry yes here
and
then actually the sulfates what happened
is the callback diverges callback libra
divergence test failed and we can see
directly that's
the expectation that we had about the
distribution and the observed value is
different that made the test fail
and also that's pretty nice like you
start with that
when if you want to
to start with that when you want to
debug what's happening in your data set
and yeah that's it
so show you how you can sorry uh start
this off the live code i still go back
to the presentation
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yes
so
show you how you can build data unit
tests i will now share a bit more how we
tackle that at get your guide
and so for that
i will explain
uh i would like to explain how we uh how
we introduced a
data unit test but
first let me share some of the incident
i actually trigger these initiatives and
if that feel
similar to what are things that sounds
good could happen to your company yeah
that's probably
time to add things like that so actually
what happened in the past is like for
example we have a change in the data
structure uh that led actually to
introduce some duplicates uh in our
recommendations
we also had another time where we had uh
we discovered that we had a missing
feature that we use for our daily
prediction data sets
and also what happened once is that we
use the wrong column actually that was
to select for the scoring of the our
recommendations so
that's not
a
great thing that i think that's thing
that you can prevent and so actually we
took action to make sure that this kind
of thing do not happen again
and what we did is actually for example
great expectation now we use it to
validate our recommendations and
and before we push them to to production
um we also introduce uh some in-house
validator with actually some integration
with this data dock
that's
push
uh uh sorry that pushed some metrics to
that dog and it said some other thing if
we have some uh something that are going
wrong so that we use to validate our
main events that we use for our pipeline
and also to our output predictions
and finally recently we also introduced
some health check as part of our
continuous integration
pipeline and also that is also run daily
uh
in our in our runs
to do our predictions
and yes
with that
um
our conclusion so
here in this presentation i try to share
the importance of testing your data
especially in your data products that's
it's actually commonly accepted that you
should test your code but i think that
we don't discuss enough about
testing the data
but it's as important or maybe even more
and i think that's the moment that need
more awareness
and i think like from what we have so we
don't have a silver bullet that we use i
get yoga at the moment
so that we can use to validate all the
data that we have
but now as you see we tested multiple
approach but there is no clear winner
that we say oh we can use that for all
use cases and yes it's quite exciting to
see the space evolving there are
libraries that pop up and that evolves
and
yeah looking looking forward to the
future
this space
thank you
[Applause]
do you want me to come to you
it's better otherwise i don't think the
people online were here
you were talking about pandera as an
alternative but
we were actually looking at using both
guide expectations in pandera just
because of this difference in like
runtime checks kind of thing especially
for services i guess pandera can do some
stuff that
you could miss if you run daily with
great expectations or something just
wondering if you had any thoughts on it
so in using pandera and great
expectation together yeah
um
so i think there is still some overlap
was like great expectation can actually
also check that a column is an integer
or this thing but
yeah but i i
i i
i agree i
i didn't so i was more deeper into great
expectations than pandera what i when i
looked into the the api it felt more
like it was more rented with thing with
going to pidentic and like checking each
row more than
like if you look at all the checks that
you can do about like statistical tests
that you can do about like the
uh the distribution of your
of your colon and things like that i
think great expectation is much more
advanced than uh
uh that pandera
but using both i mean i think like
more tests you have safer you are i
think like and
they they cover more different edge
use cases you can solve
some better with
one library and some with the others and
uh actually we have a big pro like we
are mainly using uh pi spark and when
last time i checked and when we looked
at it it didn't have support for price
park and that was like a no-go for us so
now that they i introduced that and i
will look deeper into that
thank you
i'll come to you
thank you thank you for the presentation
um so do you find that introducing extra
data tests besides the unit tests
increases deployment time or how do you
manage that
so since you said that you include these
data tests in the continuous integration
do you find that
the deployment time becomes unmanageably
slow
so it depends so we have two use cases
where we're using it and actually
you you can sample your data when you
want to do that
um or you run on everything and if you
have a large dataset then it's taking
time so in one of the use cases we can
easily sample it and actually it's
running like two three minutes so
great we don't need that i mean we don't
have this problem the other one is
taking quite some time and the problem
is we don't have a good way to sample it
smartly but
we prefer to wait like four hours and
make sure that
it makes sense like the data set makes
sense instead of just pushing it and
hoping that the next day it will it will
work so
and for hours actually if you if you
have a pr uh
usually the time that someone else uh
review it and everything
it's not well it's like it's not a one
week that you need so it's it's still
reasonable but yes it's slowing it's
throwing us us
in this yeah thank you
any more questions you can raise your
hands okay i think you had your right
hand raised for a while
i'll do a quick one uh so thank you i've
never used this and it's quite
interesting but you said in the very end
that it's no silver bullet so i guess
there's some limitations and i'd like to
hear your words and on what what can't
it do
yeah so actually i
i expect
so i
yes uh so great expectation actually we
we did some uh i did some presentation
entirely like it's actually great for
pisc and
it's also integrated with the airflow
that we're using send detail report by
email and like you can directly see what
are the expectations that fail and just
leaving that doc is pretty exciting so i
don't know if uh everyone has problem
with like documentation of data data is
changing the documentation is not
changing as fast
but
uh one thing that is quite tough is the
data breaks integration
i think that's
pretty like i skip through you can look
into the code but
everything is based on a jupiter a
jupiter notebook basically and if you
want to integrate the data bricks they
have their own notebook which are not
jupiter notebook and that makes things
more complicated it's not impossible
actually but then you have to understand
much better the the
the great exploitation library
and
uh the second thing is actually the it's
quite a new structure to investment
actually it's not
it's not like in 5-10 minutes you will
get it running and you can put that in
production like it's a huge machine and
they have a lot of concept that you need
to understand this expectation like
these are slicing these data sources
that you need to combine with other
things so it's taking time and actually
it's also evolving quite fast though
they changed the api some parts have
been updated some other pattern have not
been updated
so
and i suspect it will continue to change
so that's that's the main challenge that
we have with great expectation the other
approach are handmade but then we don't
have all the greatest features that
you have with
a nice library like that
uh anyone else has questions please
raise your hands
many people okay we have time
he was asking for quite some time
short question do we have
experience on data tests with text data
uh great question no we don't we don't
have so much
uh
text
uh that we are testing but
i
yeah you will need to to write your your
own test i i don't i haven't seen
anything in the great expectation
library about testing that
yeah
if you can raise your hands again please
okay i'll start with him
thank you uh can you elaborate on like
the different use cases where you could
apply data unit tests and where you
found it most useful for example like
validating new input data or maybe
validating like different test sets for
being a fit for actually your training
so we are
we are mainly
using it for
input and output so inputs for example
let's is in-house event validator that
we use like we have
we have events that we use to train our
model like we need to know how many uh
how many people viewed these activities
we need to know how many people click on
it how many people book them afterwards
and so then we need to kind of pipe them
together so this are the visitor id then
we need to combine it with somewhere
else and that's that's how we want to
check that
if the if the schema is changing in some
way and that
suddenly we have a problem and like we
don't have any match
anymore we want to be alerted of that
that means that some team somewhere
change the way they they handle or send
the events and we should allow that
because then suddenly we don't have any
more bookings or something like that
so that's how we use that on the input
and now the output is like we want to
make sure that uh the final uh
prediction that we we make like after we
trained our model
um
that's uh makes sense and that's
actually where a great expectation
made a lot of sense so we already had
some kind of
we call it canary step uh but it was
like handmade and it was like it was
failing but we didn't know why exactly
it was failing and that great
expectation really helped us to when
it's failing now we know exactly what is
failing we know like oh this was the
distribution that we had before this is
the distribution i mean that's the
distribution that we expect that's what
we have is it's just zero there is
something wrong we should directly check
that
and that's how that helped us here
that answer your question
perfect
i think
uh yeah thank you for presentation um i
was wondering if you can share your
experience regarding um
testing the producer contracts for
example because you're now talking
mostly about the data has already landed
somewhere
you know for example an s3 or some data
storage
and then you start to
use it
inside the machine learning algorithm
could you share maybe experience how can
you avoid having
faulty data
in the data lake itself i don't know if
you have some contact between the
producer of the data or something else
in place
so if we if we have just to make sure i
understand the question you're asking if
we have some kind of contracts between
the producer and uh
yes we we have of course that's
that's
we
we have we have documentation around the
data and we expect our consumer like the
the products team that are building the
different components of the website to
send certain type of events and that we
couldn't use them and we also had uh
also
how to say
uh
when they do some kind of migration
because the product evolved
things change and we
we need to uh they they do some
announcements and we have this kind of
rollback the thing is
you probably if you see some
announcement by email are you sure
that's the data structure change that
they propose will not affect your
algorithm like what we had uh in the
past like they changed that structure we
say well that's fine i mean and then we
we had some ins like we discovered that
actually we introduced some duplicates
because we were adding the same columns
multiple times it was it was
communicated before that we we saw this
information so all the contracts were
there but did we
spend
did we did we have like the really full
picture of how this change
will impact algorithm like you basically
have to read all your code
suddenly to see okay now i might have
this thing duplicates here
how will that happen and actually what
happened is like we started joining with
all the data frame and we always expect
like to have the the spine to be unique
and if and the other join was always not
unique
and every time like we are multiplying
the things uh because they are the same
one and it's not something that was
trivial to check because we always
expect that when we build the code and
when we say they change the data
structure we did not think oh that will
change this part of the code that's
that's the expectation that we had at
some point so i think it's better to
have this test and actually that's
that's why you write data unit tests
right right sorry unit test also you you
want to make sure that the thing that
you built the expected that you have
will still stand in the future
okay i think we have time for one last
question yeah
try to get to you
could you please pass him
thanks a lot for the great talk um i'm
wondering what are the consequences of
an error like is it just
an alert in a slack channel everybody
has muted anyway or is it really like
there's a data scientist that is on
pagerduty and then there's a severity
check and then if things really get out
of hand there's a whole team that then i
don't know gets to it or like what
processes have you defined when there's
actually a data error
it depends like
that's a good question because it really
depends on the error right if you if you
expect to have 10 000 rows and you have
ten thousand one and probably not the
same error than
if you have ten million suddenly uh so
what we what we do actually is
in this in this case what we do is we
basically don't push to production like
if we have a test basically we stay well
prefer use the data of yesterday than
using the data of today and so we will
not push the new the new version with
the test that failed so that give us
some time and we we know that
it's not ideal to have the data of
yesterday and still be running it today
but it's probably much better than
having
something um
having something that might be
completely wrong so that's the way we we
handle that in general and
basically we then that give us the day
like or two days the time that we need
we know that it's not ideal but we are
not like shutting down everything
because we cannot push a new version
so yeah and we get alert by email and uh
slack this way
yes and yeah if you are by the way we
are hiring so if you're interested do
not hesitate to come yes sorry
i think that was the last question
thank you